in other news Saudi Arabia has announced
tough new austerity measures aimed at
shoring up state finances which have
been battered by low oil prices and the
corona virus pandemic from July the
first it'll raise value-added tax from 5
to 15% it'll cut up to 26 billion
dollars from government infrastructure
upgrades including Crown Prince Mohammed
Salman and vision 2030 project and from
the beginning of next month its
suspending a cost-of-living allowance
for workers Ali Alamut is director of
the Institute for god´s Affairs he says
the announcement of the new measures was
expected government the economy in Saudi
Arabia has been under a lot of stress
that that's why the government would
draw 23 billion dollars from the Reserve
in March this is the largest withdrawal
from from the reserve ever in the
history of the country so and then
Moody's obviously downgraded Saudi just
a few weeks ago so we are looking at
continuous back you know problems facing
the economy and hurdles and and and hits
not only Corona has blocked or stopped
Ramadan Umbra and you have about one and
a half million people coming to Makkah
and Madinah during Ramadan but also the
height being canceled in addition
obviously to the oil price has been
decimated by Saudi Arabia itself and its
policy I don't think that the project
will ever start let the little homes
completed because the economic realities
have changed massively the oil prices
are not going to go back to where they
were a year ago for a long time and that
means that there are no money to to
throw it at this project or other
projects the needs for the country are
now greater and the resources are way
less because of the policies really
championed and led by Mohammed bin
Salman himself